Thanks to everyone who requested this video.
Stick around to the end of this video if you
want to hear about how this movie first got
my attention.
A lot of people have been comparing this movie
to Groundhog Day, because they’re both about
someone reliving the same day over and over,
and there’s even a montage in Groundhog
Day where Bill Murray constantly tries to
kill himself to break the cycle, which the
girl in this movie… apparently her name
is Tree…
"Tree, Happy Birthday."
hold up who names their kid Tree?
Is it because she’s sprouting with new life
each day, is it cause she needs to become
one with nature, is it cause the killer is
constantly trying to cut her down?
OK, I’m done.
But we see her trying to kill herself to get
out of the cycle too, and we see her just
experimenting, so there’s probably going
to be a lot of homage to Groundhog Day.
Like the fact that she wakes up to the same
song every day.
"Now put your little hand in mine..."
This shot’s got a ton of media references.
First up, a poster for They Live.
It’s a movie about these glasses that allow
him to see the truth, that aliens have taken
over most positions of social importance.
This is just speculation, but maybe tree finds
something that helps her see the truth about
who her killer is.
I don’t really know anything about Adventure
Time, you can leave your interpretation in
the comments.
I think now is a good time to also mention
that not all of these things have to have
some deep meaning to them.
It could just be that the character who’s
dorm this is likes Adventure Time, or Repo
Man, so I’m not gonna dwell on these too
much until I’ve seen the movie.
I will however point out that I thought this
was a Boston Bruins logo at first, it actually
might be the logo for the fictional college
that they go to: Bayfield University.
It also kind of conflicts with this thermos
that says Loyola University.
My theory is that’s where they filmed it,
Loyola University New Orleans, but they rebranded
it into Bayfield University for the purposes
of the plot.
Here we see a flag for said Bayfield University,
and take note of the Baby graphic on the left.
So it seems that the killer in this movie
is the school mascot, or at the very least,
someone who has access to the mascot costume.
If you’re wondering where I got the rest
of the name of the school it’s right there
on a little card, and once you notice it,
the label is everywhere.
So it seems they have a great sense of school
pride at this university.
Tree lives at a Sorority house that starts
with Greek letter K, but seems to spend most
of her time with XEK fraternity.
In this scene, it looks like the object that
the killer breaks to stab her with is a actual
bong.
I guess the killer is a part of vape naysh
y’all.
When she leaves Williams Hall, she’s approached
by this woman wearing a Tree Huggers United
shirt who asks her to stop global warming.
"Stop global warming?"
So maybe all of those jokes I was saying earlier
about her name being Tree might actually be
kind of relevant.
Perhaps the movie is an allegory for environmental
preservation with tree representing the environment
and her killer representing global warming
and pollution.
She only has so much time to figure out the
mystery of who the killer is, just as we are
running out of time to save our environment.
Birthday - Earth Day, I don’t know.
Maybe there’s something there.
Right after she wakes up screaming you can
see a poster of a comic woman screaming in
the background.
In this drowning scene, her hair is a different
color, this could be a test to see if physical
changes carry over to the next cycle.
So the original title of this film was Half
To Death, which makes a lot less sense to
me than Happy Death Day, but when I heard
the name Happy Death Day, I was immediately
interested because one of my favorite Alien
Ant Farm songs shares the same title.
"Happy Death Day to you!"
It’s also kind of funny because not more
than a month ago, a movie called American
Made was released, which is also a Fall Out
Boy song.
But anyway, I hope Happy Death Day the song
is in the credits or something when I see
the movie.
And on that note, the movie will be released
this Friday.
I’m gonna try to have a video out by then,
so it should come a day early this week.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors twice a week in October -- ring that
deathbell for notifications and I’ll see
you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.